Hold on, hold on. Hold.
Parties basically pushed him hard.
Listen to him.
There's not a part of you that respected
the Conor McGregor dare compare
yourself. Total agreements makes
martial arts, you know of all time,
part of the entire nation.
You know Conor Mcgregor, you know how
many [inaudible] you and can I ask
whoever the fuck is in Ireland?
What?
Connor would love bird
fucking if you said Connor,
you got one hour to party with
one guy hanging out with one guy.
He's picking on me Bro.
I talked shit might ask me advice.
I would like to talk to him about
his future. I have some thoughts.
I want him on your podcast so bad
man. I love that. I don't know.
We were supposed to do it a long time ago.
I had his trained around really recently.
You know,
I hope he doesn't think
that in any way that I,
I don't respect him or appreciate
him because fighters are like super,
super sensitive.
Like I've gone through that a few times.
Like I called Tony Ferguson who's
like one of my all time favorite.
Literally one of my all
time favorite fighters.
I said he was a brilliant Weirdo
because he wears like ankle weights.
He got mad at me,
he got upset and I had to talk to
him and I like try to sort it out.
I did it through someone
else and I was like, no, no,
no, no, no, no. He seems like
that. It seems like that,
but what it is is so exposed.
It's what you're doing is so personal.
It's so insane that you
like what we can brush off.
It's way harder for them.
Will you?
If you lose a fight and
someone disrespects you or
they in public sentiment
keeps you from getting a title shot,
I guess that's a significant
part of their life.
They're not used to dealing
with public reaction.
They used to dealing with his competition.
Right,
so the public reaction thing of celebrity,
it's an afterthought.
It's something an after
effect of competition, right?
You become successful and then you have
to deal with all these people around you
that want you to dance. Well, Conor
Mcgregor's in natural shit talker.
He's a great fighter,
but he's also a natural shit talker.
You want a buffalo bar? Yeah, Dude.
That's what I love about Conor Mcgregor.
Conor Mcgregor,
Bernie Sanders on,
it's a weird situation that you haven't
had either one of those people along.
I tried to get Bernie recently. He said
no, some fake Bernie contacted us. Oh,
you say you got your head right? Yeah,
that was had they got me and I said,
I'm a big fan of, I like a lot of
your ideas. I'd love to have you on.
And then it was here though. I don't
think he wants to run for president, man.
Why would he still come on? I
don't know. I don't know man.
You know what I fucking love by the way
about Conor McGregor is that he meets,
he made me really appreciate the athlete.
Who knows they're also an entertainer.
Yeah. I actually, you know,
there's, there's people that did that
like, I mean everyone would probably give,
I'll leave credit to me why it works.
I don't know why it works.
I mean that's who he is. He is, that
guy will be talking shit and sparring.
Just guys that are just funny.
Locked on him is fantastic.
And he's smoking weed and Mike Tyson,
by the way,
Mike Tyson owns a god damn weed farm.
What does it call him down? Yeah.
What is it called? Jamie?
Make that smaller please.
So we could read what the
Hashtag is. Um, used to have,
God damn, they used to say something
about Tyson something or another.
Did they edit it?